c'est la reprise pour les templiers
d'elancourt l'équipe senior rétrogradé
la saison dernière en deuxième division
reprend le championnat ce samedi 21
janvier à 20 heures à domicile contre
les vikings de villeneuve d'ascq pour
être prêt pour ce rendez vous les élans
courtois se prépare physiquement et
tactiquement depuis septembre ça s'est
bien passé la préparation on a eu
quelques blessés au début de l'année
pas mal de tendinites et c'est donc il
ya pas mal de joueurs qui ont été un peu
il s'est entraîné un pompier
hormis au remue ça on a réussi quand
même installer le nouveau système tout
se passe bien normalement se battrait
tous les matchs de pré-saison été
remportée ils ont tous réussi à
assimiler système donc on a bon espoir
de faire un bon premier match du côté
des joueurs étrangers les temples y ont
décidé de renouveler leur confiance à
l'américain jesse riddick déjà présent
la saison dernière et dirigeants ont
également décidé de recruter ben copper
un joueur de 2 m originaire de l'ohio
pour muscler leur ligne offensive
un mât qualité en football sont de
m'adapter pendant les situations de
match je promets que je suis un vrai
technicien
mon coach à l'université m'a d'ailleurs
beaucoup appris d'eux technique
il m'a également appris à devenir un
travailleur acharné ils ont commencé à
jouer quand il avait s'attend donc
forcément ça une plus grosse culture du
football ils sont nés là dedans et son
grandi là dedans ils peuvent transmettre
ce que c'est de performer au plus haut
niveau et qu'est ce qu'il faut pour
gagner dans ce sport
avant ce premier match les dirigeants
des temples ont également fixé les
objectifs les joueurs doivent aller en
playoffs et si possible remontée dès
cette saison en première division